all right so our next speaker is intro
dong he decided to hue quite precisely
to the title of the workshop beyond
differential privacy and he's gonna
propose a definition that goes beyond
just differential privacy thanks for the
introduction and it's really a great
honor to be standing here but actually
violet violating the rule because still
differential privacy yeah so so in order
to have your attention let me say
something controversial and Delta are
the wrong parameters to use for
differential privacy okay okay so this
is just too wrong for me to even walk
out of the room let me say something
more fair a single absent Delta is
usually not enough to describe the
methods in the privacy of the math of
the mechanism the entire collection of a
tindora meaning that for each non-
epsilon we have a delta that is he now
that is sufficient and we have a
equivalent but better way to do it
what'd I just say
and so the equivalent perspective is
called FTP and make things algebraically
nice and clean and now elaborate I'm
going to show you something serum
composition theorem and also a central
limit theorem which is why the title is
called Gaussian DP q for sure and
hopefully doesn't offend potential
economists
yeah so let me start with the basics
what is differential privacy so
differential privacy is the property of
a randomized algorithm there's a
property of the randomized algorithm we
are using the standard notation here and
as an S prime neighbors if they differ
by one individual so the time-tested
idea of these people is that there's
there are adversaries trying to
distinguish whether it's s or s prime
based on the outcome in NY and if they
cannot do too well then we have some
privacy
okay this is naturally costed in the
hypothesis testing language because the
others really just phases about the
setting problem right they're trying to
distinguish whether this is this case
where or is this case and to remind you
that M because M is a randomized
algorithm this and this are all
distributions I'll call them P and Q
okay so a little recap of hypothesis
testing for a test means or a rejection
rule it means when you see an outcome Y
little Y returns on number between 0 & 1
so that number is the probability you
reject meaning that you do design it's Q
and not P so for each test you have a
type 1 error and type 2 error type 1
error is minus actually P but you think
it's cute how to areas is actually Q but
do you think it is
and we have a fundamental trade-off
between these two hours I think of it as
when you are allow a larger type one
error you can definitely achieve out a
smaller type 2 error so we can ask this
question what is the smallest type type
2 error if I given a fixed level of type
1 error and this gives you a function
mapping from prior to the minimal tattoo
error
this function is associated with P and Q
so how do you know this function by T of
P Q so it still takes in alpha and
returns a minimal beta so this is the
expression the minimum is taken over all
possible tests and then it's a me and
not a naught is because of they my peers
of them okay so if we put put a lower
bound on this function then it means we
cannot achieve a small type type 2 error
so that'll mean the problem is hard to
distinguish
here comes the observation of Larry
Weisman total hyung almost a decade ago
that a mechanism is apt now the teepee
even only if the trade-off of Labor and
distributions is lower bond is about by
this function this function looks like
this so if this is basically a linear
function we have this part because the
signature of s and s prime that means
when you switch as a nice prime you
switch the MU and out alternative
hypothesis and hence your you switch
type 1 and type 2 error so you just do
this so you're definitely how if you
have this you know that we have this ok
the question you can ask is why does
linear so that motivates our definition
ago FTP for alpha which is a function
from 0 1 to 0 1 you know a metonym is
said to be FTP give the trail of a
neighbor and these distributions is
lower bounded by half and this is what
it looks like if F is the solid line and
the trade-off of neighboring
distribution looks like this then we do
have FTP and I want to emphasize that
this must hold point lines for all
numbers between 0 and 1
concern maybe that a general function is
not it's not a good cause you might want
to drag it already conditioned on it
because it could be super awesome oh gee
it doesn't make sense to use our author
also a function so I hear I think makes
sense is that we use half that looks
like this looks like a trade-off of
distributions with that then a question
arises how do we characterize a function
how do we know that a function is this
or not the ear counts the fundamental
theorem of trade-off functions a
function G 1 of Z 1 is convex now
increasing continuous and below this if
and only if there are distributions that
equals T V that is nice aiiow we can
just work with this class or function
well a lot about you know to the castle
function by category cap and you'll see
that there are some algebraic structures
on this
and another nice thing is we have nice
interpretation if this hosts and what
what does it mean it means telling
whether you're inside is harder than
distinguishing P and Q if F equals T P Q
and there are little there's a little
technical issue and I want to I want to
review with the symmetry between s and s
Prime know before when you switch the
type 1 and type 2 error you you are you
get half inverse right so I'll just
impose that F equals F inverse otherwise
I'll just take the max of 1/2 and F
inverse so that it's is very symmetric
so you can take that for a forgotten
okay so these are all definitions before
I make the first real point let me at
least tell you what the title means
maybe it's my confusion properly of what
you came up as a side effect and he
really does talk about its sting which
urges all values of L but it seems like
you're requiring it as a definition I'm
not sure I'm trying to understand what's
the conceptual logic between for looking
like these at all values about because
if I'm looking at the Alpha which is say
very close to 0.5 or even 0.5 itself
well what does it matter it's a
distinguished it doesn't meeting tries
to distinguish between s and s prime is
reasonable question but so you can
develop different kind of theory based
on different relaxations I'm just
presenting a specific kind of relaxation
and it has a lot of nice property that
ok so what is our GDP is sound it from
taking F to be a particular trade-off
function yes the testing problem for
normal 0 and gamma mu 1 I'll call this
function G so maybe this function
definition is so obvious mu GDP if
there's Gmail DP so what do you see how
cumulative it is that is the algebraic
thing I mentioned
the interpretation is even nicer even
nicer and telling whether you're inside
is harder than telling apart normal zero
on the normal normal do one so here's
our plot that gives you a sense what
effects this dysfunction you can see
that it's really similar to for those
corresponds to to have some pure pure DP
right we have 0.513 and the invisible
five point five one three
and the invisible fun here and these are
all symmetric now here comes the first
point it's uh so the equivalence of
using half and using the whole
collection what happened out so this is
the best illustrated by this just flow
so we can consider the following
question if I give you that M is FTP and
I want to I want to ask what kind of
absent Delta DP does it satisfy so
whatever you do because absent out here
corresponds to linear functions roughly
the inner function just form a linear
normal so what is the tightest possible
after now that that is the super
supporting linear function well that I
remind you it reminds you of complex
conjugate so that's what I want to mean
by obvious primal and absent data is do
if you work the detail out you have this
into the collection of up and wdp with
the up and down are related by this
function
yeah so I have argued that the
equivalents I also want to argue the
sufficiency of using F or absent out a
given equation that is actually attempt
to answer this question what should be
used to quantitatively describe Travis
so it's kind of a big question my answer
to it is a very easy tool to postpone is
what is that we do have post-processing
for for FTP
okay so post processing it can turn a
term P into P Prime and Q into Q Prime
so you sort the expect that P prime Q
prime are only harder to distinguish
than the original pH formalized in terms
of trade off is just because I want to
achieve larger type two error for this
problem than this one
so this is a fact and we do have so we
do have post-processing property Oh
okay so to argue or to answer this
question let me tell the story in a
slightly different way so i'll say that
pto despair is easier to distinguish
than P prime Q Park and in the Blackwell
sense if there's a post processing such
that first PA 2 P prime kill to Cooper
so I didn't termed this this it already
existed for more than 60 years highly
related to this campus and how should we
perceive this kind of ordering we can
it's the most straightforward
representation is a success your attic
so I just collect all the varying
qualities implied by this ordering that
I will call L Blackwell okay that's a
like a catalog that you can look it up
which one is easier which one is harder
we conform similar orderings by looking
at the quantitative description of
privacy for example if you use we use
trade-off and this is easier than theirs
in the trade-off sense if that trade-off
is less than this and if you we want to
use rainy divergence then this is easier
than this if the divergence is larger
okay so these are all valid orderings
and we can also form this kind of
listing of all valid inequalities in
January is also true and what what would
that mean so what would post-processing
property look like in this kind of
language post-processing means whenever
you have this you must have this
post-processing mean since it's easier
to this encourage English that means
this list is a subset of this list this
one Blackwell list is also a sub
collection for subset okay so these are
all these are all true
why do I complicate things like this yes
so the first punchline is that this kind
of list whatever quantity you used to
describe privacy you cannot be that this
list cannot be too short it has to
contain the Blackwell's list Blackwell
has destroyed lists minimal list that
you have to be consistent with and we
have a slightly potentially slightly
longer list but maybe mr. bean comes and
says why don't I have the longest
possible list by using this trivial
divergence everything is equal to zero
so that you have a bridging equality you
see use value so that's a the longest
possible list this one is not
informative at all so maybe this would
suggest that the list cannot be too long
your arms the great thing around it's
like well that Blackwell's list just
equal to the tradeoff list so if you
think of this as going from here to here
is routing information then this thing
is the most informative okay so this is
you may so from from here to here it's
just by heuristic and you may disagree
of this this statement but at least I
want to point out that this is a
relevant theory so far I am argue the
two points why equivalence or why
nesting informativeness but this is way
behind schedule so let me so the next
part is that this kind of FTP have
called algebra different apology because
all of this important to you and
corresponds to algebraic properties of
the function so I scheduled so let me
just skip this cool privacy I just want
to point out that it corresponds to
function composition
it's not something that's more important
the serum looks like you've a Miss FTP
then if you if you first do it towards
up something so that is substantive
scheme doesn't really matter because you
can think of it as taking a mini batch
uniform at random if you do something
first and then apply an and it's going
to be this much DP so what does this
thing do this thing does average and
come back see fine so let me explain
so first okay so I missed the point that
this line this line just like you are
trying to distinguish two identical
things then the only thing you can do is
just to random gas that corresponds to
type one error plus type two error
equals one so this corresponds to
perfect purpose so you first average out
with the perfect policy with this much
ratio and then you got an asymmetric
function f P I'll give you you better
have a symmetric thing here so you you
have to somehow symmetrize it you'll
flip it to get the red the red line it
turns out that you cannot take the max
you have to take the min and you take
the mean you get this get this done
correctly and then you come back safai
by taking the double double
you have this black that is what CP does
you can see that cpu is really above
original app so it's really amplifying
privacy so the right panel shows you
that we do we actually achieve
improvement on the original or classical
subsample theorem so so the blue line
corresponds to the classical theorem and
the red line corresponds to always we
cannot improve in terms of Epson doubt
because the original one is probably
tight but we achieve the improvement by
using more absolute Delta s by the
question so this is a bit sort of
complicated to represent because of this
minimum operation is it is there like a
simpler description and the sort of dual
you think of the collection of linear
lower bounds so the pool piece of ayah
that be mastered sorry
the proof I guess why that matter so the
proof is by reducing yeah I don't really
know if there is a nicer representation
you can look it up in the pool
so we have this improvement and the more
algebraic thing is composition the
theorem looks like this if the first one
I'll post on virus is FTP and the second
one takes in Y and outputs at Z and this
g.d.p
for for each input post mechanism that
outputs both and why y&z yes have this
tensor GDP so let me define this tensor
the intensity's tensor models the
trade-off of product distributions if
alpha is equal to TP Tod is T equals
this and the tensor is the trade all of
product distribution and that explains
why I use this there are a few
properties first it's well-defined
doesn't depend on the choice of Piko
Piko mg per second it's a community of
an associative is actually very easy to
see this perfect privacy serves as an
identity in this in this product so
these are nice algebraic properties now
this collection of tradeoff functions is
if you like the fancy word is
commutative monoid so is the collection
of symmetric trail so you may think that
I'm just wrapping things up in a nice
way but but not really saying anything
so let me show you this equations so the
first one shows you that epsilon Delta
are separable in this sense so actually
liked answering this testing of zero the
other creates just a general way to
create Delta and the second is from ugdp
if you composite k times thing is is
that exactly square root of k mu
yes so chinch bug does the first one say
there are actually two mechanisms that
you can apply sort of one after the
other
am I missing that the first one is
absolute pure DP the second one is
absolutely equal zero and Delta DP
yes so the composition would be the
optimality is that actually what the
theorem is saying yes it does about the
trade-off
not about the actual mechanisms that's
right because of blackwell it implies
that you can write any two distributions
that are epsilon Delta's
indistinguishable as post-processing of
a very simple kind of signal which is
consistent like two parts one is the
sort of randomize response and the other
is like with probably a delta I tell you
the true value we should use caution
because there is a for any SNS prime
there's a quantifier there right you can
do that separately for each pair of
distribution it's not correct that
particular statement is like that you
have to thing I just said it was like
you know is all was already known but
not in such a clean I think that the
point is that we have an equality here
it's not an inequality that's the point
so in order to explain what is central
limit theorem let me remind you what is
random variable central limit theorem
this for me is just indicating a
phenomena and small random effects no
matter what they are they accumulate who
gaussian if they're scaled correctly by
scaling I mean just divided by the
standard deviation that is necessary and
this accumulation is simple adding
things up for privacy is similar as
small privacy leaks accumulate to GDP if
they are scaled correctly and this
accumulation becomes composition and
okay so here's a a more precise
statement if you have n mechanisms each
one M is Fi
TP then the conversation is this much by
our composition theory right so this
thing is going to G know for some you if
these are scaled current now the biggest
problem is what we mean by scaled
correctly so this is okay think of this
as computing some number from this
integral as computing from some number
form fi when this number accumulate to a
constant number and - similar to similar
condition hold and we see it as scales
current time for this detail and let me
show you this very intimidating theorem
that this three kind of quantity
computed form F if they accumulate to a
constant number that we have that
composition goes to
the conversation is cheating so I want
to hide away this detail because that so
let me just show you the takeaways to
think of our mechanism by half and the
limit and their conversation is there is
a personal version this is one over
square root a square root of n away from
GE and this is a co chunk that Robbie
does this is just telling you that maybe
the theorem is intimidating for human
but it's definitely not intimidating for
machines so this is a human part this is
emotion per point-wise uniformity
towards your
they're all over the third moment yeah
right great these are just moments of
the like log likelihood ratios
specializing trapped in down at EPA we
don't have those annoying function those
we just have this condition the other
can be separately traded just like
random variable central limit theorem we
can use this entropy musikverein to
approximate things newspapers as this
thing this is really almost the easiest
kind of composition thing composition
product you can think of but even even
computing even local combination is
sharp P complete and they provide
arpita's and runs in this lifetime and
our approximation is - this is global
and
various inversion this is a plot showing
how well the proclamation is so the key
tell there are two lines the red
piecewise linear thing is showing this
function which is 1012 composition of
absent 0tp so the blue line is our
central image here on prediction so
these are really really very close and
if you want to use a single absent
dollar to describe this that composition
so there's actually some problem here
because one over square root of 10 is
actually 3 and really explain why so
paracin doesn't explain why the
approximation is so well we have an
improved version and convergence exactly
one away
we imagine dear the application this is
a comprehensive application because the
analysis or F 3d heavily depends on a
competitions theorem and also subtlety
well these are the red lines are our
central limit theorem result the blue
lines are recorded by this paper which
developed at the moment and Counting
math so so just a disclaimer that we
need we did not do any experiments we
just you're just analyzing the same
algorithm with the same parameters so we
achieve all that about
[Applause]
all right so we can control about it
over lunch
yes so remember the parable of the
privacy semester there's a photo
opportunity right now
we reserve it to hawk